Major League Baseball ratings are up 42
percent many people are giving credit
for the increase to recent rule changes
that have reduced the length of the game
the pitch clock tighter bought criteria
bigger bases but scientists at Dartmouth
have identified another potential
culprit for the viewership Spike you
guessed it global warming according to
the Dartmouth scientists global warming
has led to an increase in home runs hit
across the league the scientists have
determined somehow that more than 500
home runs over the past decade have been
due to global warming not due to all of
the steroids they're injecting that make
their heads three times their normal
size no no it is the sun monster that is
causing the home runs now I am actually
not making fun of the study it is a
clever study it's absurd but it's clever
the sort of silly exercise that
academics sometimes undertake to
demonstrate their methodological prowess
and skill by proving ridiculous points
but in this case while the study might
not prove very much about baseball it
proves a lot about global warming namely
that global warming is a catch-all
science of the gaps explanation
exploited by the Liberals to explain any
and every anomaly and more importantly
to explain the urgency of giving the
liberal Elite more money and power I'm
Michael knows this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show speaking of
athletic prowess there is a clip going
viral of a transgender fella who is
dancing ballet he was accepted to the
Royal Academy of Dance we will get to it
it's a very important story it actually
is because not only does it show some of
the absurdity of transgenderism
it shows the essence of liberalism so we
we will get to it first though back to
Power
I want to get to power because there's a
lot of chatter in Washington DC right
now about whether or not some of the
older members of the Senate are going to
move along Senator Dianne Feinstein one
of the
Democrats who is of a certain age as she
has not been in Washington in a while
she's been recuperating from an illness
there's question about whether she'll
ever get back to the Senate because she
is rather aged and then Mitch McConnell
as well Mitch McConnell suffered some
kind of an incident that has kept him
out of Washington there's been some talk
about Republicans preparing for Mitch
McConnell's replacement and the
McConnell office wants to Tamp that down
they say quote I am looking forward to
returning to the Senate on Monday we've
got important business to tackle and big
fights to win for kentuckians and the
American people
so this after he tripped and fell during
a dinner he says I'm not going anywhere
folks and I have to tell you
that's fine by me I am not a Mitch
McConnell hater I know he's not the most
conservative guy in the world I know
he's had all sorts of fights with
conservatives in the Senate
but you've got to respect the man for
his ability to wield power and sometimes
we wish that he would wield power for
more of the causes that we care about
but this guy understands the levers of
power in the Senate like nobody else and
I think conservatives all have to be
very grateful to McConnell because he
held up scalia's seat in the Supreme
Court and gave us a conservative judge
after Trump was elected and got Roe v
Wade overturned so I'm not a big
McConnell hater I respect the ability
that he has to wield that kind of power
and he shows a fact of especially the
Washington DC politicians which is they
they will cling to power until their
dying breath
Joe Biden is not going anywhere Joe
Biden
is not even a boomer Joe Biden is from
the generation before the Boomers which
is incredible to think that we went from
Bill Clinton first Boomer president to
George W bush first Boomer president to
Barack Obama is he Boomer or is he Gen X
I think he's a boomer
see well he's younger than the two other
guys and then then we went to Trump
Boomer president
and then
we went
to Biden who was older than all of the
previous ones this generation of
politicians does not want to give up
power the only thing that is going to
take them away from power is old father
time and the Grim Reaper coming and
pulling them out of office which means
that we are on the cusp of a sea change
but it's not happening gradually it's
not just the the older generation
preparing the way and opening the doors
for the younger people this is going to
happen rather suddenly so one of the
younger guys who is trying to grab hold
of some of that power is of course Ron
DeSantis
and in service of the presidential
campaign that he hasn't declared yet
Governor DeSantis has just signed the
heartbeat protection act into law late
Thursday night prohibits abortions in
the state once an unborn child has a
detectable heartbeat the squishes are
Furious about this the libs are mocking
the Santas they're saying he's he's
adopting unpopular positions that'll
harm him in the general election if he
becomes the nominee
one good on Governor DeSantis for
signing this bill
good let we just we need to take every
Victory we possibly can for the cause of
life
the right to life is not just one right
among many it is the fundamental right
from which all the other rights derive
and we kill some 800 000 babies a year
in this country it is worse than any
genocide that that we've ever seen other
than China I guess kills more people
kills more babies through abortion it it
would make the Aztecs blush it would
make those ancient Middle Eastern tribes
who sacrificed their children to moloch
it would make them blush the number of
babies that were killing so in itself
this is the right thing for DeSantis to
do but I think it's also a good
political move not just for the primary
but for the general election this is
where the squishes totally lose me
because they read a bunch of stupid
public opinion polls and they they
realize that opinion is split on
abortion and they fear that anyone
having any courage of their convictions
is going to harm them in the general
election I don't think that's true
people are persuadable by Logic people
are persuadable by conviction it's
actually the squishes who aren't very
persuasive because they don't make any
compelling argument for anything
but on this issue don't forget the two
issues where conservatives have won over
the last 50 years it's guns and abortion
coincidentally those are the only issues
where conservatives have spoken with
Clarity so good on DeSantis
good on DeSantis for doing the right
thing but also going to understand this
for doing the thing that will help his
campaign in the primary and it might
even help his campaign should he make it
to the general election all right we got
we got to encourage each other we've got
the conservatives are under such
pressure we've got to con encourage each
other one great way to encourage your
friends is to just pick up the phone and
give them a call you want to pick up the
phone you got to check out pure talk
right now go to puretalk.com enter promo
code Knowles we all know about the big
wireless companies out there they lock
you into these horrendous contracts and
if you try to get out of them early they
tack on outrageous charges that is why I
love Pure Talk Wireless where there are
no hidden fees no contracts no hassle
Pure Talk has a range of affordable
plans to choose from it takes like two
seconds to set it up I absolutely love
my Pure Talk service they have won me
over you can find the perfect option for
your needs like unlimited talk text
plenty of data for just 30 bucks a month
their 5G service is fast can assistant
does not drop my calls you get the same
coverage you're used to I mean the same
coverage at half the rate you're
currently paying saves the average
family over 900 per year it's a lot of
money not only will you save money you
will also get the satisfaction of
knowing you're supporting a great
American company the CEO and chairman of
pure talk is a U.S military veteran when
you become a Pure Talk customer you're
given the option to support America's
Warrior partnership which is an
organization that works to prevent
veteran suicide go to puretalk.com enter
promo code Knowles save 50 off your
first month five zero percent
puretalk.com promo code knows Pure Talk
is simply smarter Wireless
now speaking of things that pertain to
sex
how's that for a transition
there's this guy Chris on on Mr BEAST's
YouTube channel Mr Beast biggest YouTube
channel and this guy Chris is married
with a kid and Chris has just decided
that he's a woman now
which I imagine was not a pleasant thing
for his wife to hear a very cruel thing
to do to his son puts Mr Beast in a
terrible position because Mr Beast tries
to remain apolitical but now his
sidekick is is taking on the most
controversial issue in all of politics
right now and what is Mr Beast going to
do
as of now Mr Beast is defending his
friend and employee and he's attacking
the transphobes that is not
probably not a good winning path in the
long run because there are a lot of
transphobes if by transphobes meaning
people who just rationally understand
that men and women are different and Men
Can't become women if you start
attacking that transphobes I don't think
that's going to be great for your 100
plus million view videos but back to
Chris
I mentioned on the show I I don't really
care
about this guy Chris's opinions on
transgenderism or sex or the compositive
Body and Soul or anything like that I
don't even really care that much about
Mr BEAST's opinions on YouTube
but I asked the question
how does a guy wake up at the age of 26
with a wife and a child and decide that
he's a woman
and I suggested that the aspect of this
whole transgender phenomenon that people
are not really talking about is porn
that porn is driving a lot of this and I
I even had that thought because I was
speaking to a reporter who had done a
little bit of a deep dive onto all the
kind of weird porn I'm not I'm not
saying this reporter was sort of
prowling late at night on the secret uh
browser tab or anything like that but uh
she had gone gone down this Rabbit Hole
of a specific type of porn that men who
have rapid onset gender confusion
attribute their confusion to this I
started watching this porn which is kind
of a hypnosis and then what do you know
I can't get it out of my head and it's
melted my brain and now I think that I'm
a woman
so Ali Stuckey
our great friend Ali Stuckey dug up an
old tweet from this guy Chris on the Mr
Beast show and she said in a tweet that
he just deleted Chris from Mr Beast who
recently announced he's transitioning to
a woman says he likes lowly which is
l-o-l-i which is a form of anime porn in
which the female characters are depicted
as children or even babies
man many many such cases among trans men
I don't know what this guy Chris meant
by that comment where he had made this
whole comment about how much he lusted
after this genre of pornography I'm not
saying it means that he's a pedo I I'm
not saying it wasn't even just a joke on
Twitter but what is undeniable from this
is that this guy Chris knows a lot about
porn
if you're familiar enough with porn to
make a joke about this obscure
Sub sub genre of pornography then you
know a lot about porn which would seem
to back up my thesis which I I said on
the show is just a hunch I'm not I don't
know this guy Chris there's I haven't
read any scientific study with a lab
coat but I strongly suspect that if you
start to have really bizarre sexual
ideas and desires it might have
something to do with the ubiquity of
bizarre extremely high-tech pornography
that is warping people's minds and that
they write people write into this show
even sometimes they say I got hooked on
porn at age 10 and it's been a struggle
for my whole life maybe that's something
that politicians should do something
about speaking of the justice system
speaking of transgender identifying
people
there is a dude who thinks that he's a
chick who attacked a Catholic Church
he was finally arrested for this and
this guy destroyed religious property
this is a crime that holds a maximum
prison sentence of one year up to a 100
000 fine up to five years probation
supervised release following prison so
this is
this is pretty serious
and the Biden doj just recommended no
jail time
of course it did the Biden doj
Biden FBI which sends agents in to spy
on Catholics who go to mass on Sunday
the Biden doj and FBI which then tried
to deny that they were spying on
churches and and viewed Catholics as
potential domestic terrorists we then
found out this was a real program it
wasn't just a one-off memo that that
nobody knew about this was a program by
the FBI there were there were agents
assigned to cultivate sources to try to
flip priests to violate the inviolable
Seal of the confessional potentially and
to to rat to the federal government on
their flock
and then
a member of the protected religion the
protected Cult of transgenderism goes
and attacks the persecuted religion
Christianity and specifically
Catholicism and he gets off scot-free
this is how it works
this is how the the I don't need to tell
you that you're well aware of that
but the the liberal regime the Elites in
power with the bow ties don't wear bow
ties with the long neckties and the very
fancy jackets and they've got the really
fancy offices in Washington DC they're
not going to go out and commit Street
crime but Street crime is important for
them to maintain their political
dominance and so what they do is they
just encourage all sorts of miscreants
to commit commit the street crime for
them and then they let them off the hook
and then they bail them out of jail and
then when BLM is marauding all over the
country for eight months Kamala Harris
raises money to bail the
the criminal BLM activists out of prison
Joe Biden staffers raise money to bail
BLM out of prison so what does that do
that creates an incentive
for more of the street crime which
intimidates conservatives and Christians
and normal people
who are now going to think twice before
speaking out because they don't want
their Church destroyed they don't want
their pro-life Pregnancy Center
destroyed they don't want their homes
destroyed they don't want to be attacked
in public by people who will have
impunity to do it
speaking of corruption in the
administration
the Pentagon Inspector General has found
that corruption in Ukraine funding and
arming
is very very high risk
the defense department recognizes
Ukraine's history of corruption and
considers the possibility of Aid being
deflected before it reaches its intended
target to be a high risk
another official at the Pentagon is
concerned about weapon systems that
we're sending over there and the theft
of those weapon systems they say this is
according to an official being reported
by defense one DOD procedures the most
advanced systems in the world there are
many entities to include foreign Nations
as well as criminal groups that want to
get their hands on weapons technology
Etc which raises the question that I've
been asking since day one on all of this
Ukraine stuff namely
what are we funding
what's the goal here
because from my position it feels like
our sclerotic leaders are sleepwalking
us into World War III
what's the end goal here
we could have prevented the war easily
Joe Biden Donald Trump did prevent the
war Donald Trump is the president on
whose watch uniquely among recent
presidents Vladimir Putin did not
further invade any foreign Nations
but Biden comes into Power he could have
prevented The Invasion probably he could
have done that by maintaining sanctions
on Russia even according to the Ukraine
President Vladimir zielinski
Biden lifting those sanctions impelled
Russia to invade then what happened
then Biden said if it's just a minor
incursion we won't do anything about it
that's fine
further encourages Russia to invade
then the United States funds the war
says we're going to fund the war into
perpetuity
so now the war continues to escalate
we've got now explicit threats of
nuclear war Russia is saying it's not
even a cold war anymore Russia's saying
we are directly in a hot conflict with
the United States and then you look over
there
at China and you see China beginning to
aggress on Taiwan and the South China
Sea it just feels like we're slow
walking into World War III so what are
we doing here we're funding Ukraine to
the tune of billions and billions of
dollars over 100 billion dollars
what do we want do we want Ukraine and
NATO I don't
is that the plan do we want Ukraine and
the European Union
that doesn't seem like a great idea
either but let's tell let's figure out
what
what the plan is do we want do we want
to invade Russia do we want war with
Russia do we What's Happening Here do we
want a buffer state in Ukraine which I
think would have been smarter what are
we funding
seems like we're just funding more and
more corruption with no end in sight
speaking of arms
the head coach of the San Antonio Spurs
has a lot to say about your arms this
this was a comment he made on Sunday I'm
glad we can finally get to it here at
the end it's been a very very busy week
but I'm glad we can get to it because
it's an important comment that this guy
very ignorantly made Greg Popovich
suggested that second amendment freedoms
are a myth on the way he goes to my mind
that
I hope
they're going to be okay
and most of you in this room when we
were in school we worried if
Nancy would dance with us on Friday
after the football game or something
that was that was our anxiety
but they're going to cloak all this
stuff you know the second the myth of
the Second Amendment the freedom you
know it's just it's a myth it's a joke
it's it's just a game they play
I mean that's freedom is it freedom for
kids to go to school and try to
socialize and try to learn and be scared
to death that they might die that day
with Ted cruzzle fixing because he's
going to double the number of cops into
schools that's what he wants to do
well that'll create a great environment
is that freedom
or is it freedom to have a congressman
who can make a postcard with all his
family holding rifles including AR-15 or
whatever is that cool
so this coach is just obviously a
complete NPC this guy hasn't given two
seconds thought to the Second Amendment
to Firearms to the natural right to
self-protection he is just reciting all
the silly platitudes that you hear from
the libs and it's not his fault he
probably doesn't think about politics
very much so if he's got CNN on in the
background that's just what goes into
his head and that's what comes at his
mouth and there's a very little
conscious thought going on in between
those two things
but he makes one good point here
which is he says there's a second
amendment of freedoms that's a myth
it is a myth that's true it happens to
be a true myth it happens to be a myth
that tells a story that speaks to a real
truth which is your right to
self-protection but we tell it in the
form of stories and it's embedded within
our history and we see it in our legal
documents and unfortunately what the
Liberals have done in our modern era is
they have
demystified the world we're so damn
disenchanted we just look around the
world it's like Hamlet he looks out he
says I've I've lost all my Mirth
what a piece of work is a man you know
what what look at the sterile Promontory
this this Brave or hanging firmament
fretted with a golden fire it just it
seems to me no other thing than a
sterile Promontory then the man is this
quintessence of dust what what
Shakespeare was seeing occur in our
culture is what has totally come to
fruition now which is we just live in
this disenchanted world we need more
myth in the world we need more narrative
we need to recognize that we're not just
bags of chemicals but we are characters
in a story and just because something is
a myth doesn't mean it isn't true
now speaking of good stories you got to
check out nefarious you know I'm a tough
critic it's pretty obvious when I don't
like something well there's a new movie
opening today April 14th called
nefarious that looks and sounds like
another completely forgettable horror
film let me tell you why this is
different it's not a horror film it's a
realistic psychological Thriller that
becomes a supernatural Thriller it's
about a serial killer about to be
executed who claims he's a demon the
psychiatrist is called in to see if the
man's going crazy or is faking Insanity
just to get off the psychiatrist is your
standard ivy league guy doesn't believe
in demons God any such nonsense but he
doesn't quite realize what he's up
against the film is surprising and
thought-provoking something you
definitely need to see head on over to
see nefarious opens Nationwide starting
today April 14th go to who is
nefarious.com and buy your tickets today
that is who is
nefarious.com for tickets
my favorite comment of the day is from
the drummer's workshop at Norm's music
man that guy it just has so many
favorite comments of the day who says
Bud Lights stock dropped lower than Leah
Thomas's Voice come on folks
my favorite comment my favorite aspect
of that comment is the come on folks
because it just turns it into a Rodney
Dangerfield routine yeah yeah yeah yeah
my hero my yeah bud light's stuck drop
lower than Leah Thomas's Voice come on
come on folks hey my wife my doctor
Vinnie boombots okay speaking of
performances
this is an old clip
but it's it's making the rounds now the
clip goes back to 2017 2016 something
like that
it's making the rounds now because of
the transgender Madness that has been
going around the culture it is of a man
an older man it's not not a
16 year old ballet dancer he's an older
guy who always wanted to be a ballerina
but he can't be a ballerina he could be
a male ballet dancer but he can't be a
ballerina because he's a guy and he
decides well he's going to pursue his
dream anyway
and he's accepted to the Royal Academy
of Dance this very prestigious school in
the United Kingdom so someone cut two
videos together one of this man who
identifies as transgender dancing ballet
and one of
an actual young ballerina
let's just take a look
so they're they're dancing
the same ballet
and
if you're only listening to this right
now as a podcaster on the radio I I
cannot do it justice
the the man who was who was accepted to
the Royal Academy of Dance
is
[Music]
is not dancing any better than I would
right now if I were imitating how he is
dancing and the young woman is a
ballerina and ballet is really beautiful
I like ballet a lot and
the difference between good ballet and
bad ballet is instantly apparent ballet
is a very difficult
type of performance and it requires a
very specific body type and very
specific training and very specific
Grace that
women have more than men do now
obviously there are men who dance ballet
and they dance the male roles in ballet
and that too requires a very specific
type of training and a very specific
type of body and then you've got this
guy
who obviously should not have been
accepted to school I'm not just trying
to make fun of him here
he's not even a male ballet dancer that
I guess that's the craziest part to me
about the whole video that's the
craziest part about him being accepted
he's not even a male ballet dancer he's
just a deluded guy
who no one has had the compassion to
tell him is
living out of fantasy
that and and so then people make fun of
him
and that's very sad had someone in this
guy's life gone up to him and said hey
you're not a woman you're not a woman
you're not a ballet dancer you're not a
dancer of any kind
there is such a defect in your
perception that not only are you seeing
the wrong sex when you look in the
mirror you're not even seeing that when
you try to plie or you do uh you know
whatever any of the other ballet dance
moves are it looks
like a caricature of someone making fun
of someone who's telling a joke about
someone who is doing ballet that's
that's the what's so striking about it
is that this is not just a problem for
transgenderism
this is not just a problem for the
radical left agenda this is this is a
problem with all of liberalism
which is that all of liberalism because
it Embraces a radical individualism it
erodes standards
liberalism begins with the idea that we
are fundamentally individuals
traditional political thought begins
with the idea that we are fundamentally
the political animal we're social
creatures we're coupling beings we live
in society and much of our identity
comes from a role in society and we have
obligations to society and to Nature and
to uh Nature's God right liberalism says
no you're an individual you can do
whatever you want you can be whatever
you want
but then then that erodes standards if
we're told
everybody can go to college and
everybody should go to college and
everybody has the same natural capacity
to do everything that everybody else
does what's the consequence of that
we've all seen it at colleges we've all
seen it at schools at the lower level
from college
standards erode it's not that it brings
everybody up it just
it just brings the people who are
excelling down
this is the story by Kurt Vonnegut of
Harrison Bergeron that as individualism
and egalitarianism and liberalism
pervade Society
you're going to see a leveling of
society a leveling down where people who
are excellent are not allowed to excel
the ballet that this guy is elected to
elected too that this guy is accepted
into
is going to be much worse
and because ballet is not an
individualist
endeavor
The Talented dancers who were supposed
to dance alongside him they are going to
be worse the whole production is going
to be worse because of it and that
lesson applies Way Beyond transgenderism
that lesson applies to all of the
delusions that liberalism voiced upon us
and the lesson applies to all of society
do we want to be a society in which
people cannot excel in which we just
level down and to protect the delusions
and the narcissism of all the people we
pretend that reality is other than it is
or are we going to be a society that is
grounded in reality that says hey
hey Hank maybe ballet is not for you
maybe you ought to try welding or
Plumbing or something like but you could
be very good at that but you you
whatever else you are you are not you're
not good at being a woman and you're not
good at dancing ballet speaking of
protecting Society some good news out of
my own state of Tennessee
the Tennessee house
yesterday and proved new measures aimed
at heightening school safety at both I'm
sorry this I actually was last week
new measures at heightening school
safety at both public and private
schools this was a way to after the
terrible shooting in in Nashville to arm
the schools make sure that if someone
tries to shoot up the school there will
be plenty of good guys with guns to stop
that shooting before it can really even
begin and what do you know the three
people
who led the riot at the Capitol those
three lawmakers who had a vote taken to
remove them from Office one of them
survived by one vote but the other two
were removed from office
those three did not vote for this bill
why
because
it's never been about protecting kids
the Democrats
who go on and on and on about how
Republicans are allowing kids to die
because we don't want to repeal the
Second Amendment
they have not proposed any laws that
would have stopped any of these major
school shootings in recent years they've
never done that obviously
they uh
have encouraged children to engage in
behaviors that are extraordinarily risky
that encourage risk of death just even
the idea of encouraging transgenderism
which now has exploded among young
people one in five Zoomers identify as
LGBT even specifically on the T though
rates of transgender identity have
exploded by 50 100 or even more in
recent years among specifically young
people and transgenderism is associated
with higher rates of anxiety and
depression and suicide so if you wanted
to protect young people you'd probably
want to keep a lid on that delusion of
transgenderism the libs are doing
exactly the opposite they're trying to
trans people as young as five as young
as Elementary School and frankly even
younger
was never about this the libs are always
trying to pass their assault weapons ban
even though the quote unquote assault
weapons are used in a tiny fraction of
murders each year
it was it was it's always about the libs
pushing the same old narrative and even
even when an incident like a school
shooting
has no connection to the law they're
trying to pass they'll go after it
gets back to what we're talking about at
the top of the show Major League
Baseball now has more home runs because
of uh what I don't know global warming
libs are Relentless they never give up
and and this should be a lesson for
conservatives who think that the the
only way that we can ever win in the
culture is to concede and find some
conciliatory middle ground because
listen certain issues we've just lost
okay we lost the debate we don't want to
turn off independent moderate voters and
so let's just squish on everything and
give it up and just move on and try to I
don't know maintain some tax cuts or
something that's never going to work and
the people who do wield the power in
society the Liberals they never do that
they never give up
anything that happens they're pushing
the same policies that they've been
pushing for 100 years and they're so
relentless about it that very often they
get what they want this was the topic of
my speech last night at UW Superior I'm
up here in beautiful Wisconsin the
speech is on the Y A F YouTube channel
so you can go check it out in its
entirety I'll try to get a full copy of
the speech and text up on daily wire at
some point today
but you know I got to keep my blood up
okay I gotta I gotta keep my nutrition
up and I've got to get a lot of iron
going through my my blood and when I
want good nutritious delicious food
where do I turn turn to good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com use
promo code Knowles if you have not
changed the way that you buy meat yet
you need to let me give you three
reasons that I personally subscribe to
good ranchers first off they are giving
you free bacon for a year
when I first heard that I just didn't
believe it they're you're just getting
free bacon it's a 240 value that is a
pound and a half of bacon in every box
second good ranchers offers a price lock
guarantee meaning that when you
subscribe your price doesn't change for
the length of your subscription what a
great way to beat inflation it's an
unbelievable deal especially now with
record high inflation lastly the product
is unlike any other they're all natural
Burgers USDA prime steaks better than
organic chicken have changed my standard
for grape meat it will change yours too
use my code knowlescana wles for an
extra 20 off your order
I did not know that meat that you
ordered that came in the mail regularly
could be this high quality it's just
amazing I I have good ranchers for if
not most of my meals at this point at
least a plurality of them I I hate this
stuff I all the time I just love it the
quality and I am such a stickler about
my meat quality it is the best in the
business goodranchors.com use promo code
nulls for 20 bucks off your box free
bacon great meat secure price bonus 20
bucks off today promo code knows
goodranters.com goodranchers.com
American Meat delivered it's hard to
believe it's been less than a year since
Matt Walsh released his groundbreaking
documentary what is a woman even harder
to believe how much is transpired since
then what is a woman helped to spark a
national debate about what our children
are being taught where this country is
headed if you have not had a chance to
see what is a woman I have some good
news you can now get 30 off your daily
wire Plus Membership when you use code
woman if you've not seen the film or
know someone who hasn't tell them to
watch it it's time that more people came
back to the side of truth and reality to
watch what is a woman join now at
dailywire.com subscribe use the code
woman to save 30 off your membership
finally finally we have arrived at my
favorite time of the week when I get to
hear from you in the mailbag the mailbag
is sponsored by pure chocolate if you're
talked at Knowles uh puretalk.com select
a plan and then enter code Knowles to
get 50 off your first month let's take
it away
with the voicemail back
hey Michael the last few years
conservatives have rightfully been
pushing back against self-proclaimed
experts like Dr fauci because it affects
the way we live our lives but we have
also over corrected in my opinion when
we say things like science is fake and
now there's a general feeling that I get
to have an equally valid opinion as
someone who knows way more than me just
because I can think
I don't agree with this
if there was a debate between you and
some random teenager
that doesn't really follow politics
I don't think anyone should be expected
to pay a cent to go see that debate for
obvious reasons
and when the daily wire hosts talk about
movies for example no offense but the
only person's opinion who I care about
is Andrew Clavin
so what is your response to that do you
feel the same way about expertise than I
do and what do you really mean when you
say things like science is fake I
appreciate your response thanks
when I say science is fake I'm not
saying that the experts are idiots
the experts often are idiots or the
experts often are
ignorant or the experts often are
corrupt that's true that's what we saw
during covet but that's not what I mean
when I say science is fake when I say
science is fake I mean that the premise
of Science and a society that grounds
itself on science and purely empirical
study the premise is that reality
fundamentally is physical and empirical
and observable under a microscope and
that isn't true
the reality fundamentally is
metaphysical
at the very least we have to acknowledge
that physical and metaphysical reality
exist and the scientists following the
empirical scientific method don't have
very much to say about metaphysical
reality and metaphysical reality
comprises all the things that we hold
most dear our loves our Joys our dreams
our souls our
virtue by yourself all the things that
really matter and that we struggle with
and we're pursuing and we're trying in
the case of Vice we're trying to refrain
from that's metaphysical and so the
scientists can't be the top dog experts
in society but I do turn to other
experts when I want to know about a
great many questions I turn to a long
dead expert who is living in heaven
because he's a saint that would be
Thomas Aquinas
so I'm happy to take that expertise
I take the expertise of priests I take
the expertise of butchers when I want to
go by Meat I take the expertise of my
tailor when I want to get my pants
hemmed I take all sorts of expertise and
I I have no problem with that and I have
no problem with hierarchy and I have no
problem with the natural emergence of an
elite which have happened in every
single Society what I have a problem
with is when people overstep their
bounds when they make basic
epistemological errors and when they
pretend that they are the vicar of Truth
when when Dr Patrick says I am the
representative of science
in science
is the finest greatest Authority on all
the Earth bow down to me you peasants I
am your emperor that I have a big
problem with that because
it it's it demonstrates that even if Dr
fauci did know something about
epidemiology which I'm fairly skeptical
of actually he he doesn't understand
even
the the basic aspects of more
fundamental questions epistemology
ontology anthropology certainly theology
which which we don't even recognize in
society anymore one of the most
important speeches of the 21st century
was a speech by Pope Benedict XVI at the
University of Regensburg and he joked
there he's at Regensburg has a Catholic
faculty and a Protestant faculty in the
theology Department
and he said it's wonderful to be here at
Regensburg where the university has two
faculties for something that many people
today don't think even exists so so
that's my problem with the experts we
just need experts who understand even
the very basis of expertise next
question
hey Michael my name's Nick love your
show was watching earlier this week and
the discussion related to the FBI
um going undercover in the Catholic
church and you had mentioned something
about how the
uh the confessions are invaluable I
believe I'm using the correct word there
and I just wanted to know what your
thoughts are on how that relates to
actual serious crimes that maybe uh
someone who's confessing uh committed
um I think I know the obvious answer
here but I just wanted to you know make
sure I'm clear on it and get your
thoughts so you know in this instance
that someone comes forth with a very
serious crime
you know I certainly think that the the
priest has a moral responsibility to you
know communicate that to the local
authorities
um and you know likewise if the local
authorities that believe that person has
committed a crime and you know something
was said in confession that
um the priest thinks is relevant to that
you know I think they also have a duty
to report that at there as well so just
want to know what your thoughts are on
that and um you know how that how that
you think that that would work out thank
you love your show again and all that
you do
thanks so much I'm glad you asked the
question because your uh intuition of my
response is not correct the Seal of the
confessional is inviolable
period end of story
the priest cannot go out and Report any
sins that you confess in the
confessional it is inviolable it has to
be inviolable
because when you are in that
confessional you are talking to God and
the priest is acting as priests
or want to do in Persona Christie
dispensing the grace of God and the
Forgiveness of God
but you are confessing all the bad
things that you do all of them if you
don't confess all the bad things that
you do and you walk out of the
confessional intentionally you you will
commit a further sin not only will you
not be forgiving your sins you will
commit a further sin of sacrilege
so you go in there and you confess all
the nastiest most terrible things that
you do if that seal is not perfectly
inviolable
people cannot go people will not go to
compassion and you will not cleanse your
souls the confessional for
by Catholics and by Christians broadly
for most of our history is the laundry
mat you know it's how you it's how you
clean your soul and you have to do it
regularly it's it's an important
Sacrament that Christ institutes when he
says here here is the power to forgive
sins whose sins you forgive are forgiven
who sins you retain are retained
inviolable now does that mean that if if
a guy goes in and he says Hey I just
murdered a bunch of children and I'm
hahaha I'm gonna get away with it that
the priest does nothing that he can do
no the priest has the power to forgive
and retain so if the priest suspects
that the penitent is not actually
penitential you can say well I I can't
forgive you your sins I can't absolve
you of your sins because you're not
actually
a penitent
uh the priest could strongly encourage
the penitent to turn himself over to the
authorities to explain to the penitent
that an an outward sign of his
having changed his ways in his his
remorse of what he's done would be to go
to the authorities and turn him in and
give information about the crime so the
priest has options there but no the
when you were in that confessional you
are speaking to God about very very
serious things and what you are engaging
in is the cleansing of your soul and and
the the request from God for forgiveness
no one breaks that nobody next question
hi Michael RJ here I was wondering what
you thought about mail order brides that
being the practice of marrying a woman
from another country after only meeting
her in person once or twice it's
certainly something with a long history
monarchs arranged marriages and such but
I wondered what your opinion on these
marriages were are they a viable option
for older or even younger men looking to
marry what would you recommend to
someone looking at this option thanks
always love the show
really interesting question
I'm not opposed to it in principle
it's probably not the ideal way to meet
your wife I don't I doubt that young
people dream about someday I'm going to
open up a catalog and find my wife or
something like that but I don't see
anything wrong with it in principle I I
understand why
some Modern people would have a problem
with it in principle because we now have
these modern Notions that marriage is
purely about romantic love and and
marriage is purely about uh
you know happenstance and your own
personal individual choice and there's
no formality to it but as you point out
that that hasn't been true for most of
History marriage is the fundamental
political institution and it's
sacramental and it it
is when you leave your father and your
mother and you you come together with
this new person you create a new family
with that person so if there's some
formality or something unusual about it
that's fine the marriage is still a
marriage and I suspect it could probably
work out pretty well
I would definitely make sure that you're
on the same page about what the marriage
is and you make sure she doesn't just
leave you once she gets her green card
but uh otherwise yeah marriage is a good
thing and you don't need to
be living in a Hugh Grant movie or
something like that for the marriage to
be good you don't need to just you know
happen upon them in a coffee shop one
day and then that's the only way to have
a good marriage no marriage is a good in
itself and so as long as you're both
engaging in a real marriage you don't
even know what you're signing up for
wonderful okay last voicemail back
question
Michael so I am very pro-life
which also means that I am not pro IVF
the idea of putting a child in a freezer
this is not not a very good thing in my
opinion
over Easter weekend
I found out that my sister plans to go
through with IVF
this coming year
and I'm just really torn because her
doctor plans to implant one at a time
and discard the rest after I think she
said four or five years
and I'm so torn because I absolutely
love my sister I will love any niece or
nephew that comes out of this
but I just I don't know how to approach
this I don't know if my sister knows how
I feel about it and I don't want to
bring it up to her and upset her I'm
just kind of in a weird awkward
situation
so I would love any advice thank you
love your show
thanks so much your sister very likely
doesn't know a lot of people don't know
they haven't thought about it this is a
new technology a lot of people don't
spend their days mulling on bioethics
and and so your sister might
be
sincere and think that she's committing
an innocent act but it isn't innocent
not in the way that the materials are
collected not in the way that the
embryos are formed and certainly not in
the way they're discarded also known as
killed so
if she has not gone through with it yet
I think you have an obligation to tell
her
lovingly you're not you know not to
castigate her but just to say hey sis do
you know what this really is do you know
when they use this language of discarded
we're going to reduce the number we're
going to we're going to create and these
are words for
can kill conceive child it's not an
embryo it's a child you know it's a it's
Offspring so I think you've got an
obligation to tell her that before she
does it if it's already happened
that complicates it a little bit more
and you might you might broach the
subject in an even softer way but to ask
what's going to happen to these embryos
that have been created but if you're
catching this early enough you I think
you've got to tell her how you feel
because how you feel happens to be
correct
the wait is over folks
the yes or no pre-order is complete
games are shipping now you can order
right now at dailywire.com shop games
are going quickly and supplies will not
last the last time we did this we sold
out instantly we're actually a little
bit worried that we can't make these
fast enough so you got to order now to
secure your copy you know there was a
pretty long backlog on these on these
games uh plus we've got some really fun
stuff with the games coming out into the
future we'll make an announcement about
that a little bit later now is the time
to get your copy though I'll say uh this
is something you do not want to miss out
on order yes or no the game only
available at dailywire.com shop
now we're here and I'm I have to tell
you I've got producer Colton here with
me today
now you can hear producer call he's he
not only is the human Corgi as Ben
Shapiro says but just sounded like a
corgi as well by barking when I said his
name producer Colton has brought me my
iPad so I get to chat with you in the
membrane segmentum which begins now head
on over to dailywire.com Knowles I will
need your help to ascertain which of the
headlines are fake which of them are
real dailywire.com Knowles use code
notes you'll get two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
oh